dans le saloon d'un cowboy city la
partie de poker approchait de sa fin le
shérif 1 est horrible jack le bandit
avait mis tout leur argent sur la table
il ne restait plus aux deux joueurs qu'à
montrer leur carte 1 le shérif posa les
siennes sur la table tatras s'écria-t-il
horrible jack eu un horrible sourira et
posa ses cartes lui aussi en dix ans de
son horrible voit cinq as j'ai gagné
qu'entendu léonard
entendu coin
horrible jack a encore gagné la partie
de cartes avec le shérif 1 les huit
dames anse et un nom rime le tricheur au
enfin voyons comment oses-tu dire ça qui
ne connaît rien aux cartes et est
horrible jack et mon envie préféré alors
s'il te plaît tétouan et bien qu'il
devrait continuer la lecture qui tu
verras qu'il a triché
ça ne m'intéresse pas et je vais te
prouver qu'on peut très bien gagner de
l'argent aux jeux sans tricher coin sont
très jus sans tricher impossible
impossible eh bien tu vas voir je vais
jouer toutes mes économies à casimir
enfin ce sont toutes des économies tu es
fou mais non non pas du tout tu verras
jean rapporterait eu 200 milles même
avec atlanta casimir oui mais ya pas de
m tu vas voir horrible casimir va
devenir le plus grand joueur de lille
aux enfants
vous avez entendu
monsieur casimir ie6 tête de bull
il ne s'est même pas souvenu que dans un
jeu de cartes il n'y a que quatre ans
l'as de coeur as de trèfle l'as de pique
l'as de carreau
horrible jack est un tricheur puisqu'il
en avait 5
je crois qu'il est temps de donner le
son à casimir
allons
monsieur du snob oui
bonjour c'est moi casimir allez on a non
six mois des ennuis bon merci vous oui
oh on se sera sûrement une très belle
sculpture en allant louis non mais
laissez moi parler monsieur du snob bon
j'ai quelque chose de très important à
vous dire oui
c'est un secret
rendez vous tout à l'heure
sinaoui vous êtes prêt fin prêt
montsarrat julie tu ne bouges pas de
tokyo ce qui est tu prends l'air de rien
un petit peu comme ici au moins d'accord
attention attention le voilà
[Musique]
salut nazi je veux bien faire un jeu je
suis désolé casimir j'ai un travail fou
il bien parmi eux pourquoi
françois tu veux bien faire un jeune et
bon désir casimir le tuc nos julio au
ping pong là à la pétanque
odano non non non je veux faire en jeu
où je puisse gagner de l'argent
désolé casimir mais je ne joue jamais
d'argent aux jeux ça ne m'étonne pas
poids tu as peur du grand joie horrible
kazemi
bon j'aurais peut-être plus de chance
avec monsieur
bonjour monsieur du sne à bâle un bon je
m'envoie casimir que me veux-tu je
voudrais savoir ce que vous faites avec
cette pièce un jeu joue un terrible jeux
d'argent tu vois pyla ou pas mais c'est
formidable vous tombez bien vous avez
devant vous horrible casimir le plus
grand joueur de lille a lancé la règle
atmel est très simple horrible casimir
il suffit de lancer la pièce en l'air tu
vois et quand elles retombent si ces
piles et bien je gagne et si c'est face
tu perds d'accord je suis votre homme on
joue un franc par coup d'accord alors
attention je lance la pièce up pile je
gagne face
tu perds
pile je gagne
pile je gagne face
tu perds mon stop ça suffit on doit
savoir en france
je n'aime pas du tout ce jeu
si c'est pile je gagne si c'est face du
père pile je gagne face tu perds c'est
curieux il le sent qu'il ya quelque
chose de pas normal
pied je gagne
françois marié je viens de voir leonard
au téléphone je suis au courant facteurs
casimir est au fond du jardin allez-y
amusez vous bien merci
aux casimir salut salut tu es tout seul
j'attends quelqu'un pour faire un jeu et
gagner de l'argent et bien le voici j'en
connais un formidable attendez ce n'est
pas tout faire seul pour sûr nous en
casimir bonsonnois ya un petit ennui
c'est que j'ai j'ai un gros avantage sur
toi on dit donc si vous insinuez quand
je suis plus gros que vous ce n'est pas
vrai allez expliquer moi votre jeu bon
et bien voilà le jeu consiste à mettre à
la main derrière le dos ouais et a
montré
plusieurs doigts ensemble ah bon moi
comme ceci tu vois par exemple la doua
d'accord j'ai compris j'ai 4 juillet on
y va alors on livre alors à tant attendu
de pension ensemble 2,3
alors comment sait on recommence année
encore oui oui
on attendait ça y est j'ai compris oui
bon wagon attention
on a gagné tous les deux à nous à nous
nous nous avons quasiment anneaux tu as
quatre doigts et moi j'en ai cinq tu
veux toi 4 francs 4 france est vraiment
voilà
quatre ans
merci
il ya quelque chose de pas normal
qu'il
fasse
[Applaudissements]
casimir tu veux faire un jeu avec moi
tiens il me reste une pièce dans la
frange est montante la donne et tout de
suite il m'a
dit tu sais que tu avais attrapé la
maladie du jeu wii et pour donner une
bonne leçon nous avons très hachée de la
faune on a tout en argent quasiment à
des facteurs pas avant qu'il nous ait
chanté sa chanson heureusement les
enfants je veux bien d'accord musique
quand j'ai voulu saluer dès la fin du
terrier d'à côté
j'ai mis ma tête dans leur cour
mais coincé jusqu'aux
genoux frais
malheureusement les enfants
iv m'attend
ils m'ont tiré et fort par les pieds et
j'ai pu respirer
[Musique]
tout en haut d'un mur de pierre pican
lézard vert je dansais
quand il a dit on descend j'ai senti
tout mon sang se glace et
les enfants
sont arrivés à temps
ils ont tendu une ouverture j'ai pu
santé du mur
[Applaudissements]
leurs feux dans l'île aux enfants jeunes
chanteurs joliment mes chansons
si j'ai la croix qui dérivent ma mémoire
qui défaille
attention
[Musique]
oh
à temps
[Musique]
témoin en plus
tazi
mais oui
mo
[Musique]
il est arrivé
en bas
[Applaudissements]
voilà
oui
ouais et alors
[Applaudissements]